any of you who've read my my book about
what happened know that I think that
misogyny and sexism was part of that
campaign it was one of the contributing
factors and some of it was old-fashioned
sexism
and a refusal to accept the Equality of
women and certainly the Equality of
women's leadership so even though the
majority of married women voted for
Trump all women lost when Hillary did
that of course was Hillary Clinton at
Georgetown University just yesterday
blaming sexism for her 2016 defeat which
apparently is still top of mind the
remarks come just days after she was
denounced for tolerating sexual
harassment on her very own campaign team
lighting people is Hillary Clinton's
primary public pastime for the past year
watch the use of my email account was
turned into you know the biggest scandal
since lord knows when I was on the way
to winning until the combination of Jim
Comey's letter on October 28th and
Russian WikiLeaks raised doubts in the
minds of people who were inclined to
vote for me but got scared off if you
look at Facebook the vast majority of
the news news items posted were fake
there's all these stories about you know
guys over in Macedonia who are running
these fake news sites
he's certainly interfered in our
election and it was clear he interfered
to hurt me and to help my opponent
there was voter suppression people
trying to prevent other Americans from
being able to vote I also think I was
the victim of a very broad assumption I
was going to win I inherit nothing from
the Democratic Party look I take
responsibility for every decision I made
but that's not why I lost it's possible
it's easier to find public appearances
by Hillary Clinton that don't involve
blaming everyone in every place from
Manhattan to Macedonia we haven't found
one yet Brit Hume is Fox's senior
political analyst and he joins us
tonight nothing makes me feel more
sympathetic to Hillary Clinton Brit than
appearances like this because I think
this is
someone who was no one in her life who
can pull her back and tell her how she's
coming off to other people
tuckered she reminds me of other
prominent people I've known who have
made a terrible mistake had a big
failure yeah run into trouble and they
have a very hard time some of them
owning up to it and admitting that they
were involved in a colossal failure and
they are to blame because when you think
about her failure here her failure to
win this particular election she was up
against Donald Trump a man with with
whose favorable ratings were deep
underwater throughout virtually the
entire campaign the electoral college
math appeared to favor her
overwhelmingly the polls all said she
was leading and it didn't seem possible
she could lose and yet she did that is a
very very hard thing yes it's up to but
I think she is doing her best to find a
way to look at this and a way to frame
it that makes it appear that she really
wasn't all to blame and otherwise you
know I don't know what she'd do if she
didn't have this this crutches she's
developed of all sorts of other reasons
but I mean that's to turn this into a
Bible study or anything but you've lived
a long time and don't you think that
it's true that when you accept blame for
things when you realize that your
failures are your fault it's liberating
it's good for you you feel better when
you do that yeah I agree with that I
vote in every now and I'll get it asked
to make a graduation speech and my
message is always the same to young
people
own your mistakes admit them first of
all to yourself and then to anyone else
that might be involved and it is
liberating and attendee and the peculiar
fact of it is that contrary to how it
might feel to you it almost always ends
up making people think better of you
than less yeah you know it's something
that but I think in her case the burden
of this is so great and the burden of
acknowledging that in the end it was
really up to her to get out and win the
election and she failed to do so against
the candidate who looked on it looked
like he couldn't possibly win so here we
are I would say by the way Tucker yeah
we regard to hurt those most recent
remarks that one she made yesterday I
don't think that the it's the case that
America isn't ready for female
leadership
and for a woman president they were just
not the country turned out not to be
ready for this woman to be president
remember of course she turned out not to
be as she refuses to admit a very
effective candidate and she comes with
tremendous baggage which he's always
been hesitant to recognize as well going
back to her days in Arkansas and right
through her husband's presidency and
beyond
I think that's examining the obvious
lesson last election is America's pretty
open mind it's certainly open mind
enough to elect the right woman I would
say but thank you very much it's great
to see you
you bet Tucker